if your call was to prove he's innocent
and went back the court of public
opinion I don't think this text message
is actually doing the job this is not
your Smoking Gun unfortunately this is a
display of psychology that now is only
going to make people argue and more
dividing
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to talk a
little bit more about Jonathan Majors
we're not doing daily videos on this but
uh John and I we want to do a live
stream catch up on a bunch of movie news
manyana that's tomorrow in Spanish by
the way for you racists out there
tomorrow in Spanish we know people will
be asking about this we want to keep the
movie news as much about a bunch of
other things and not have it this only
be about shot at the majors I know we're
gonna be asked about it yeah let's just
get this out of the way in one video and
then we'll focus on the live stream and
hopefully be able to talk about a bunch
of other things what do we got well
Jonathan's Majors his lawyers is trying
to give us major updates to prove his
innocence in the court of public opinion
saying all kinds of crap to the public
and release in all kinds of stuff the
biggest development it was this text
message that the lawyer it's a lady
lawyer right yes indeed sir I don't know
they can do law now what
you know what well we walked in one day
with a big book of the lawn argued her
weigh-in and now it's president that's
wild what's this country coming to next
it'll be dogs doing the law
that seems a lot more fair uh it's a
man's best friend of course he's
thinking who gets seniority so guys so
here's what's going on that was all
satire by the way I hope it's a love of
God you people pick up on that
terrific start there's these text
messages that came out because there
were statements released a big one
claiming that we have video evidence to
show that that incident that took place
in the vehicle we got other Witnesses
and I was like wow really okay when you
get the opportunity release the video
evidence so that'll speak way more
volumes than anything else that you have
to put out there and now there's these
text messages this exchange from I'm
assuming his ex-girlfriend boyfriend
girlfriend now like I don't know what's
going on with it it remains to be seen
especially I mean given some of these
developments you apparently recanted
hardcore so who knows this text message
it's interesting going through it I can
see how you know as a from a lawyer
standpoint especially if you have like a
jury or something or like this person
claims this you have to go off of that
and then there's the other side so
there's like two there's two discussions
to be had about this I don't know what
to believe John doesn't know what to
believe no I know the answer I know how
this is exactly what happened you can
get two camps that go like this
definitely proves he's innocent and you
got another camp that goes well I
wouldn't be so sure about that I kind of
want to just explore both sides right
now yeah we're gonna speculate about
what's happening I'm not saying it's
it's this way or the other I just want
to kind of discuss it a little bit see
where we land here or maybe not land who
knows see what happens in the comments
section yeah what do you guys think
there is gonna be a very fun video to
engage on so here's how the text message
reads say please let me know you're okay
when you get this they assure me that
you won't be charged they said they had
to arrest you as protocol when they saw
the injuries on me and they knew we had
a fight I'm so angry that they did and
I'm sorry you're in this position we'll
make sure nothing happens about this I
told them it was my fault for trying to
grab your phone I only just got out of
hospital just call me when you're out I
love you and then a couple hours later
that was at 6 PM they just called again
to check on me and I reiterated how this
was not an attack and did you not have
my blessings on any charges being placed
I read the paper they gave me about
strangulation and I said Point Blank
this did not occur and should be removed
immediately the judge is definitely
going to be told this she insured this
to me I know you have the best team and
there's nothing to worry about I just
want you to know that I'm doing all I
can on my end I also said to tell the
judge to know that the origin of the
call was to do with me collapsing and
passing out and your worry is my partner
due to our communication prior out of
care she promised all will be relayed I
just I mean this is a lawyer's dream
yeah like we got her to sit there for a
canceled look she put it in writing for
us and then the most specific term yes
and there's all kinds of speculation
that I've heard that I'm like yeah
anything sounds possible in a lot of
ways this is Hollywood we're talking
about sure I could imagine that if the
situation actually did go down with the
way the allegations are being made that
uh feige and Victoria Alonso got
reinstated and we're like what are you
doing
all those people with sunglasses roped
off the area how much money is this
gonna cost right can you send these
messages of course like NDA for you yeah
there's no evidence to support that but
stuff happens and then yes there is that
cyborg I did question going okay do I
just need to read this in a different
tone because I know that text messages
can be very confusing in tone and you
know and what has the discussion with
them been like prior to these text
messages coming out you know this is in
the midst of papers being released John
the majors upset like there's so the
problem with this text message release I
believe the whole point was to win back
people in the court of public opinion
that was the main point when I first
read this a couple things stood out to
me where I go sure it can prove his
innocence and then the other side when
you if you're slightly familiar with you
know abusive relationships this can read
like a victim trying to appease or
abuser oh totally and I'm not saying
that's what's happening it I'm saying
that it could completely also but it
checks a lot of those boxes yes and it
also aligns somewhat with other accounts
that have come to light in recent times
I read this statement first when I was
talking with John prior to filming
because that's the thoughts we were
having said let's go online and see what
other people are saying sure and I'm not
gonna quote anyone I don't have anyone
else's opinions pulled up here yeah this
is the problem a lot of other people are
also going well I don't know if this
actually proves he's innocent I've sent
this text myself in a state of duress
just because someone has an abuser
doesn't mean they're not you know
toxically and passionately in love with
that individual codependent on them yeah
and they'd be so scared and that they do
anything they can to appease that
individual it could so be that or it
could completely be we're just reading
into it yeah yeah exactly this could
just be the exact literal face value
recanting of all these circumstances it
appears to be and my point with that is
if you if your goal was to prove he's
innocent and went back the court of
public opinion I don't think this text
message this is actually doing the job
this is not your Smoking Gun
unfortunately this is a display of
psychology that now is only going to
make people argue and more divided to
pinpoint just even a couple of sentences
where it just sort of raises questions
like I said I we don't have all the
context surrounding it and for the love
of God if you're putting out this text
message you better be working on that
freaking video coming out as soon as
possible or at least some of the other
eyewitness testimonies or something you
got to the point now we're like well now
you gotta definitely release that
yeah yeah because if this is really just
not what happened we want everyone to
know that that's the easiest Direction
like when saying things like I told them
it was my fault for trying to grab your
phone that could easily read like it's
my fault while we got in a fight and you
hurt me now she doesn't say anything
here but that says you physically hurt
me she just says like we got into a a
fight you definitely didn't strangle me
I don't want to speak for what the
relationship is I'm saying that it's not
our place to need all the context but
you're putting this out for the public
to basically judge and to throw their
opinions in there and now I'm like well
now I got a bunch of questions and
opinions I have no idea where to go
especially like okay why'd you go to the
hospital what is this thing that you
collapsed and passed out from yeah and
where did those other injuries come from
and what do you mean mean when you say
that it was my fault trying to grab your
phone what is it that you're referring
to I'm not gonna be here and be like
Jonathan Majors definitely did this I
know other people who are 100 said would
absolutely say that and I know a lot of
people who are like you know this
completely proves he's innocent and to
me I'm here going just release the
goddamn video If you really have that
release you're touting that like you
could have this all over tonight yeah
this is It's fascinating and yeah it's
just one of those situations where all
we can do is sit and wait and you can't
really form any opinion or a solid
conclusion I should say this only gets
us away further from a solid conclusion
I feel like just my spiritual metal
detector when I wave it over this
doesn't feel right about the whole
situation I feel like the truth is
probably more likely somewhere in the
middle and is probably very messy that's
the only Vibe I'm truly getting out of
all of this like they're trying to spin
this as something so cut and dry of like
no no like the morning after it was so
Swift it was like no no everything you
just heard none of that and I feel like
you know if you're going to change your
grave this is a weird metaphor but if
you're going to change you know a
failing grade make it like a b or
something don't make it just a plus it
seems like they're trying to spin it
into this woman has mental health
problems and that's where all this is
coming she's crazy and she's trying to
tear this guy down which is like the
cool essential story you would want to
weave out of this if you're trying to
hide your ass maybe she does have mental
health I got mental health problems like
we all should we all the most of us
probably have some kind of mental health
condition we're dealing with right it
seems like that's occurring in one way
or another I just don't know how much
Jonathan majors does or doesn't have to
do with it it's making it more confusing
this video is not going to really have a
conclusion because it's like the
situation doesn't happen we're further
away now that we were before yeah like
it's not conclusive evidence literally a
couple days ago it was just okay well as
soon as we get that video maybe we'll be
fine and now it's like why why'd you
lead with this yeah what message is this
sending I haven't condemned him yet but
I'm also very much kind of waiting to
see what the conclusion is before giving
him an Ezra Miller pass which even that
is I don't know like there's been such
comparing and contrasting of these
different situations and I'm sure the
main difference there it's like pretty
easy to kind of quantify it for me in
that regard a ton of people made
the Flash the movie was already shot
yeah you know and delayed and all sorts
of other stuff so just release it just
get this over with because also we know
you can recast yeah it's not that hard
it's not like you hung your hat on us I
think Warner Brothers should have oh one
thousand percent addressed what the hell
is going on with Ezra Jonathan Majors
only has Loki done you know yeah like
and just get others by the way I did not
intend I was wearing this for a
completely different video
where it is yeah yeah so I mean do you
have this better get resolved before
what June July whenever Loki drops yeah
I'm like that's different now you have
to recast you know you have to reshoot
Victor timely so yeah this is it's it's
diff it's a different situation to me
where do you guys land on it leave your
thoughts down below sure they're
Pleasant yeah I'm sure everyone's gonna
keep it clean in the comments all right
guys well we'll talk with you all soon
[Music]